Heute im Rasenfunk? Der blickt auf andere Nagen.
Da ist sie wieder, die Liga Tour von vielen, das Lieblingsformat inklusive von denjenigen, die sie machen. Ich freue mich sehr, dass ihr alle da seid, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und was soll ich sagen? Heute haben wir wieder alle Ligen mit dabei. Serie A, Premier League, La Liga und die Liga ist mit dabei. Und deswegen begrüße ich als erstes Alexis Menuge, wie schön dich mal wieder in unserer Runde zu haben. Hallo, Alexi.
Guten Morgen allerseits und ich freue mich auch, wieder dabei zu sein.
Ja, da wollen wir jetzt nicht so sehr ins Detail gehen. Aber schön, dass auch Nils Kern hier ist. Hallo, Nils. Und Uli Hebel ist wieder da. Hi, Uli. Ja, genau. Da kann niemand mithalten. Mit Alexi und Nils kann niemand mithalten. Und Christian Bernhard ist hier. Wobei, du könntest mithalten. Hallo, Christian.
Hallo in die Runde. Schönen guten Morgen.
Wir haben heute die Herausforderung, diese Sendung kompakt zu halten. Deswegen wollen wir gar nicht lange schnacken, dass der Rasenfunk crowdfinanziert ist. Bist du inzwischen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Wir gehen gleich rein in die Themen und wir starten mit der Liga, weil wir jetzt so lange nichts mehr zu Frankreich gehört haben. Alexi, mit welchem deiner beiden Themen möchtest du beginnen?
Fangen wir mal an mit dem einzigen trans- frischen Champions-League-Sieger der Geschichte, Olimpique Marseille.
Was ist denn da schon wieder los?
Ja, viel Unruhe, wie immer. Ich habe wahrscheinlich in den letzten Wochen auch schon mal die Ausschreitungen der Fans gegenüber den Vereinsoberen thematisiert und jetzt haben wir auch noch eine ungewisse Zukunft. Soll der momentane Eigentümer Frank-Marc Hurt aus den USA-OM verkaufen? Soll die Arabien schon längst Interesse haben oder auch nicht? Also es gibt immer wieder Gerüchte, aber es kommt nichts und die Fans machen sich tierisch Sorgen, weil Marse ist der populärste Verein Frankreich, nach wie vor vor PSG, über 60.000 Zuschauer im Durchschnitt und die sehen alles plusgangs Fußball seit Wochen. Die Mannschaft wird bei jedem Transfermarkt jetzt wieder im Winter fast komplett ungekrempelt. Könnte sein, dass Gattuso den Winter nicht überlebt, dass man also einen dritten Trainer in dieser Saison hat, nach Marcelino und Gattuso. Also keine Kontinuität, kein klarer Plan, kein klares Projekt und das ist schon traurig, weil man würde schon gerne einen zweiten starken Verein haben in Frankreich hinter Paris und der kommt nicht und Marcel Dümpel dahin ist jetzt in der zweiten Tabellenhälfte. Nur in der Europa League sieht es gut aus, aber es genügt einfach nicht und wenn es so weitergeht, wird der Olympique Marseille in der kommenden Saison nicht europäisch vertreten sein und das wäre normal oder verdient, muss man sagen, weil man sieht, wenn du jede Saison 10 bis 15 neue Spieler holst und verkaufst und dann wieder einen neuen Trainer, dann beginnt man einfach bei Null und da weiß man nicht wirklich, was der Sportdirektor früher war und jetzt Präsident Pablo Longoria will, macht und tut. Und auch wenn das Schall und Auswirkung jedes Mal, wie gesagt, ist es auch sein Verdienst, aber das ist das Einzige und das ist einfach zu wenig.
Ja, nur drei Siege aus Wurscht spielen, das ist wirklich sehr wenig für Olympique. Du hast jetzt ja schon quasi benannt, wo das Problem ist, zu viel Umbruch in jeder Saison und ja auch dann diese finanzielle Ungewissheit mit neuen Besitzer und so weiter. Aber trotzdem verstehe ich das nicht so ganz. Also woher ist einfach der Sportdirektor nicht in der Lage da etwas kontinuierlich aufzubauen? Liegt es daran, dass das Umfeld ja schon ein Besonderes ist? Es ist ja jetzt auch eher mal unruhiger als ruhiger bei Olympique. Wo sind da die Gründe für?
Wie gesagt, es gibt keinen Sportdirektor, weil er ja Präsident geworden ist vor zwei Jahren.
Okay.
Dieser Posten wird aber in wenigen Stunden von einer der größten Bayern-Flops aller Zeiten, die Benatja besetzt.
Ehrlich?
Ja, natürlich. Ich sage ja, Circus Olympique Mausel geht weiter. Und zuletzt war er noch Spielerberater. Und die Verhandlungen dauern an, weil er muss aus seinem Vertrag rauskommen. Und es ist halt auch von der Verwaltung her ziemlich kompliziert, dass er sofort von heute auf morgen vom Berater zum Sportdirektor wird. Aber die haben sich die Olympique-Poste auf ihn festgelegt. Und es wäre für ihn natürlich eine super Aufgabe, weil er ja auch aus der Gegend kommt. Aber ob er das kann, ist wieder hinstellen. Und auch der Berater des Vereins, Schaffa Papa, wie Franz-Peter Maurer sagen würde, der ist auch ziemlich orientierungslos, beziehungsweise auch rufungslos, weil er sieht, wie sein Verein sich nicht weiterentwickelt, kein kleines Konzept hat. Und er ist ja vor allem ja als spezieller Berater eingestiegen. Und seitdem hat sich nichts verbessert, im Verein überhaupt nicht, nur bei der Mannschaft, wie auch. Und deswegen macht er sich auch gewisse Sorgen. Und ich glaube nicht, dass die Personalie Bernhardt ihn dabei beruhigen wird.
Und was ist die Qualifikation von Mehdi Bendat hier, außer, dass er aus der Gegend kommt und eben Spielerberater ist? Er hat doch vorher noch nicht so einen Job gehabt als Sportdirektor.
Genau, es ist ja seine erste Station. Deswegen ist es schon ein Riesenschritt für ihn. Also die letzten zwei, drei Jahre, seit er seine Karriere beendet hat, ist er gar nicht so lange her, ist er Berater geworden von verschiedenen naokanischen Nationalspielern, unter anderem von Unai, den er zufällig nach Mazzar gebracht hat vor einem Jahr jetzt. Jetzt sind wir sehr gespannt. Er hat zwar ein gutes Agenda, so viele Kontakte der Branche, aber er muss sich trotzdem noch finden. Ob er, wie gesagt, Mazzarri wieder nach vorne bringt, ich glaube, wichtiger ist einfach, was der jetzige Besitzer will, ob er bleiben möchte. Es gibt immer wieder Gerüchte, dass er einen Verein für 400 Millionen Euro zu verkaufen wäre und dass da Saudis interessiert wären. Aber das sind, wie gesagt, keine konkreten Sachen und das hört man schon seit zwei, drei Jahren. Das ist aber der große Traum von dem Olympique Marseille-Anhang, dass der Verein verkauft wird und dass da richtig Kohle fließt, damit eine stark kräftige Mannschaft endlich mal auf dem Rasen steht.
Aber das heißt, für 400 Mille könnte ich Olympique mir kaufen? Das ist ja 1,25 Mal härter WSC. Das ist ja ein Schnapper. Also rasenfunk.de/supportersclub, liebe Leute. Ja, das Projekt steht. Das ist absolut so. Also fantastisch. Und das Medi Benat ja zwei Jahre jünger als ich. Das nehme ich als persönliche Kränkung hin, dass der jetzt dann Sportdirektor werden will. Aber gut, ich habe irgendwie das Gefühl, Alexis über Olympique werden wir noch sprechen in dieser Saison. Das ist glaube ich nicht das letzte Kapitel. Jean-Pierre Papin. Das hatte ich schon wieder total vergessen, obwohl du es schon mal erzählt hast. In einer Ligatur. Wunderschön, wunderschön. Wunderschön ist auch der Tabellenführer in der Liga. Zumindest wenn man nicht so ganz genau hinguckt, ehrlicherweise. Wir haben es schon mal thematisiert. Es ist aber schon eine Weile her. Und inzwischen ist Girona mit 34 Punkten aus 13 Spielen. 2 Punkten vor Real, 4 Punkte vor Barca. Und das ist die größte Überraschung dieser Liga. Der beste Angriff der Liga spielt in Girona. Was hat sich da getan, Nils, dass das jetzt so kontinuierlich ist? Ich weiß noch, dass wir damals darüber gesprochen haben, so wie so eine Momentaufnahme.
Ja, damals wirkte das noch Ende September. Das war ein bisschen wie Momentaufnahme. Die haben einfach guten Saisonstart, vielleicht nicht die ganz großen Gegner bisher noch nicht getroffen. Aber sie stehen immer noch da. Obwohl sie ja auch gegen Real Madrid verloren haben. Da war ich noch vor Ort dabei, als Real Madrid dort dran gewonnen hat. Aber musste auch in der Anfangsphase ziemlich zittern. Also Girona überrascht gerade sehr viele in Spanien. Haben jetzt auch nach dem 2. Sieg bei Rayo Vallecan das 6. Ligaspiel auswärts in Folge gewonnen. Das schafften zuvor in der Liga-Historie nur Real Madrid und Barca so eine Serie. Überhaupt 11 der 1. 13 Spieltage zu gewinnen, das schafften auch erst Real Barca und Atletico. Da entsteht irgendwas Besonderes. Und irgendwo ist es auch ein bisschen das Fortführen einer kontinuierlichen Arbeit. Trainer Michel hat die Mannschaft aus der 2. Liga hoch in die 1. Liga geführt. Dann gab es letztes Jahr schon einen guten Platz. 10, auch so knapp hinter Conference League-Platz hätte fast noch reichen können. Und jetzt wird da erst mal weitergemacht, wo sie letztes Jahr angefangen haben. Also, dass du da auch siehst, dass da eine junge Mannschaft ist, wo schon vieles einstudiert ist, wo du viele Umschaltmomente hast. Wenn einer im Mittelfeld den Ball erobert, dann starten sofort ein, zwei Spieler ihre Motoren, werden dann ganz gut bedient. Du hast gerade Top-Spieler, die super in Form sind. Ich glaube, hier im Rasenfunk wurde schon mal Savio thematisiert oder auch eben Arten Dovbjeg. Der ist jetzt mit 12 Torbeteiligungen gemeinsamer Platz 1 mit Jude Bellingham. Also, da funktioniert aktuell einfach sehr, sehr viel, sodass Girona wirklich für den besten Offensivfußball in der Liga aktuell steht. Atletico auch nicht so weit weg aktuell. Aber da macht Girona einfach viel Spaß und viele wundern sich, wie das kommen kann. Aber es gibt viele Gründe.
Ja, unter anderem ja, dass man zur Manchester City Football Group im weitesten Sinne gehört, also auch aus Abu Dhabi finanziert. Also, das heißt, Savio wird jetzt dann, also Dovbjeg ist wahrscheinlich schon zu alt mit seinen 26. Mit so alten Spielen möchte sich Pep Guardiola nicht mal abgeben. Aber Savio, den sehen wir dann bei City nächstes Jahr, oder wie?
Ob es dann City gleich wird oder so, gibt ja noch ein paar andere Clubs in diesem Netzwerk. Aber an Savios da kommt aus diesem Netzwerk Alex Skassir genau. Und dann gab es noch Jankl Herera, der hat letztens für ein wichtiges Tor gesorgt gegen Celta Vigo. Aber immerhin, sie setzen auch eben ganz gut auf die Jugend. Und speziell dieser Artem Dovbjeg, der kam irgendwo aus der Ukraine. Den hatte scheinbar kein anderer Club aus, auf dem Radar. Und der hat jetzt einfach schon mal 12 Torbeteiligungen. Also, ich sage schon auch immer dieses Sternchen dazu, ja, die kommen halt einfacher an Top-Spieler dran als vielleicht Alaviz, Cardis und Co. Aber sie haben eben auch andere Spieler, wo sie viel Potenzial drin sehen. Auch noch Martinis, Top-Rechtsverteidiger, Miguel Gutiérrez, Top-Linksverteidiger. Also, da funktioniert schon sehr viel City Group. Deswegen habe ich das Wort Märchen hoffentlich nicht verwendet.
Oder? Es kommt nicht aus dem Vakuum. Aber wie geht das Umfeld damit um? Ich meine, die Hintergründe, die kann man natürlich kritisch sehen. Aber die Geschichte ist ja, wenn du Fan eines Zweitligisten bist, und Girono ist ja schon lange in der 2. Liga gewesen, oder? Und dann kommst du nach oben. Und jetzt aber drohnst du sogar an der Tabellenspitze, ist ja schon was, was man sich eigentlich wünscht als Fan.
Was heißt wünschen? Ich glaube, da sind in der Stadt auch viel überrascht, wie einfach das aktuell geht, weil du auch auf einmal diese ganz schwierigen Spiele gewinnst. Ich habe Celta Vigo angesprochen, da gewinnen sie 1-0. Hätten eigentlich durch den Schiedsrichter Entscheidung eher 0-1 zurücklegen müssen. Im Pokal knapp und spät gewonnen. Ossasuna haben sie 4 Torschüsse aufs Tor abgegeben und 4 Tore gemacht, so gewonnen. Jetzt Radio war auch ein enges Spiel trotzdem gewonnen. Also da klappt schon mal sehr viel. Aber vom Umfeld her ist man fast gar nicht darauf vorbereitet, noch höher zu spielen oder Champions League zu haben. Als ich das erste Mal im Monte Livi war, das ist ja das kleinste Stadion in der Liga, da schon sehr provisorisch steht, auf Gerüstbau, Stelzen. Du hast jetzt keinen massiven Bau, da ist eine sehr schmale Gänge, die ist immer noch in den Kuletten, in Containern und so weiter. Um das Stadion drumherum ist keine Gastronomie, da sind ein paar Buden am Spieltag aufgebaut. Aber das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt, wo man sagen kann, da fassen auch mal Champions League-Heimspielereien. Das fände ich spannend, wenn es so weit kommen sollte. Das sieht ja erst mal ganz gut aus, dass sie vielleicht Platz 4 erreichen könnten. Die anderen 3 Plätze sind ja meistens vergeben. Aber das Umfeld ist da schon auch selbst noch überrascht. Man weiß noch nicht genau, ob man das wirklich halten kann. Aber irgendwie steht man immer noch da. Zu Saisonbeginn haben wir noch gesagt, jetzt fehlen nicht die großen Spiele noch. Aber trotzdem sind sie noch da oben mit 11 Siegen aus 13 Spielen. Also fantastisch, ohne dass das kleine Girona darauf vorbereitet ist.
10 Punkte Vorsprung sind es gerade auf den 1. Nicht-Champions-League-Platz. Klar, die Saison ist noch lang. Aber mal gucken, ob wir Girona in der Champions League nächstes Jahr sehen. Ich weiß noch nicht, was ich davon halte. Aber ich habe auch noch nichts von ihnen gesehen. Also, wer bin ich da zu urteilen? Etwas gesehen habe ich allerdings von Chelsea. Denn Uli, man kam an Chelsea nicht vorbei. Erst dieses 4 zu 1, was man gegen Tottenham geholt hat, mit der Besonderheit, dass Tottenham zwei rote Karten gesehen hat und trotzdem auf Höhe der Mittellinie verteidigt hat. Und es ging sogar ewig lange gut. Erst in der Nachspielzeit die ganzen Treffer. Und dann jetzt ein spektakuläres 4 zu 4 gegen Manchester City mit jeder Menge Gesprächsstoff danach. Inklusive Entschuldigung bei Pep Guardiola. Ach, ich hab ganz vergessen in die Hand zu schütteln, weil ich hab mich so geärgert, dass wir den Angriff zum 5 zu 4 nicht ausspielen konnten. Da war einiges los. Wenn ich dann allerdings auf die Tabelle gucke, dann ist man aus Chelsea sich dann doch ernüchtert. Immer noch Platz 10, 16 Punkte, während Manchester City 12 Punkte mehr hat an der Tabellenspitze. Also was ist da los in London?
Also du weißt ja, ich bringe immer ein negatives und ein positives Thema mit. Das ist schon das Positive. Lass es mich gleich erklären, weil ich komme natürlich bei Chelsea um den Begriff Märchen nicht umhin. Ist ja klar, weil man, wer so wenig Budget zur Verfügung hat und dann am Ende auf Platz 10 steht, dem muss man ein Märchen gewährleisten.
Und fast ohne Roman Abramovic. Da hat man jetzt ja irgendwelche Zahlungen vorbei. Jetzt eventuell nachgewiesen. Vielleicht hat er sogar nach seinem Ausscheiden noch da finanziert. Das ist ja wirklich Wahnsinn. Wie Chelsea das mal schafft.
Das glaube ich natürlich nicht.
Das ist Fake News wahrscheinlich.
Alles im Bereich der nebulösen Dinge, die so nie stimmen. Nee, im Ernst. Also Chelsea klar, Platz 10. Das ist Teil der Wahrheit, dass das letztlich nicht ausreichen würde. Aber die Erklärung ist, in der Art und Weise sieht das sehr, sehr gut aus inzwischen. Und so, dass ich das überhaupt gar nicht angenommen habe. Ich habe immer behauptet über Chelsea, dass die logischerweise einen sehr, sehr talentierten Kader haben, mit viel Geld aufgepolstert. Inzwischen, der Talente schub mir überhaupt europaweit. Haben auch vielen das Business zerstört, unter anderem Borussia Dortmund zum Beispiel, weil sie eben die Talente einfach schon mal aus dem Stegreif für 20, 30 Prozent erhöht haben, weil sie eben Interesse haben oder vielleicht sogar mehr gemacht haben. Also Cole Palmer, da werden wir dann gleich nochmal einen Besonderen drauf zu sprechen kommen, der für Dortmund dann einfach nicht mehr leistbar war, auch wenn sie ihn vielleicht sogar gerne gehabt hätten. Aber, und das ist der Punkt, ich habe nicht gedacht, dass Mauricio Pochettino so schnell ein Team formt, das in allen Belangen von der Art und Weise her gut genug sein könnte. Der hat am Anfang im Angriff mit einem 4-2-4 gespielt, hat jetzt umgestellt auf die klassische Fünfer-Struktur vorne drin mit, wenn er gesund ist, das große Fragezeichen leider, Rhys James, auf einer absoluten Schlüsselrolle, rechts draußen in der Verteidigung, hat in Cole Palmer den Spieler identifiziert, der, glaube ich, diktieren kann wie kein anderer das Tempo, den ich maximal auch unterschätzt habe, ehrlicherweise. Fast sogar schon ein bisschen zu sehr auf ihn zugeschnitten alles, aber das liegt eher an den Spielern, glaube ich, und nicht so sehr an Pochettino, der das gerne haben möchte. Und dann ein Kader, der überdurchschnittlich athletisch ist, der überdurchschnittliche technische Fähigkeiten hat, jung ist, also selbst auf Abwehrpositionen, bis auf Thiago Silva, der wird halt einfach sein Leben lang da spielen, aber ansonsten sind es vergleichsweise junge Leute, die sehr vieles tun können, also sehr versatil sind im Einsatz. Und wenn jetzt noch ein bisschen taktischer Intelligenz links oder rechts dazu käme, dann glaube ich, haben die wirklich einen der aufregendsten Kader Europas. Ich meine, nochmal, da kommt dann der Bereich Märchen rein. Das ist jetzt auch nicht komplett zufällig, wenn man sich einfach die besten 60 Talente Europas holt, dann wird schon irgendwie mal 5, 6 werden dann schon kleben bleiben. Insofern okay. Und ich möchte auch immer dazuschicken, das ist alles nur so lange gut, bis irgendwann mal Clearglay Capital und Ekbali einfach wieder in den in den Meetingraum stürmen und sagen, komm lass uns was machen, lass uns Deals machen. Ich hätte mal wieder Lust, was zu verändern am Kader. Deswegen immer das Sternchen dran. Die Kultur ist entscheidend bei Chelsea. Und wenn aber jetzt Ekbali den mal machen lässt, da Pochettino, dann haben sie einen guten Trainer, den ich ebenfalls unterschätzt habe nach der letzten Station in Paris und einen super Kader, den ich nicht so schnell in der Art und Weise da gehabt hätte. Es sind ein paar aufregende Spieler dabei, wie Nicholas Jackson auch, der noch nicht so ganz clever ist im Laufspiel und so. Das sind halt alles Dinge, an denen jetzt Pochettino noch arbeiten muss. Aber offensichtlich ist er jemand, dem diese Situation besser gefällt, als mit Superstars zu arbeiten. Da kann ja Alexis ein Lied davon singen. Er mag wohl offensichtlich lieber ein junges Team komplett aus dem Nichts erschaffen, als er gerne mit absoluten Megastars arbeitet. Wenn man in dessen Gesicht blickt, zu Paris-Zeiten habe ich immer das Gefühl gehabt, der Arme sollte immer eine abholen von da, wo er ist und ihn einfach wegführen. Aber jetzt, der grinst manchmal sogar.
Aber wie ist es dann zu bewerten, dass man jetzt so gute Ergebnisse hat, aber dennoch insgesamt so schlecht dasteht? War das jetzt einfach nur der schlechte Start? Ist es die Unerfahrenheit, dass dann eben doch hin und wieder ein bisschen was fehlt, um gerade gegen unangenehme Gegner Tochter zu erzielen? Woran liegt das, Uli?
Expected Goals-Werte sind auf dem Level von Manchester City. Aber sie haben sie bis auf die letzten zwei Spiele nicht unbedingt gemacht. Du hast ja Tottenham schon mal angesprochen. Ich hielt das im Übrigen für die komplett richtige Taktik. Mein Bruder hat das ja kommentiert, ich habe Parallel-Immam geschrieben. Es ist nicht so, dass Eintracht Poste Kogel einfach das durchziehen möchte, sondern der hat gesehen, die pressen manchmal so naiv, dass man die immer überspielen kann. Deswegen glaube ich, hat er das so lange gehalten, weil er wusste, irgendwann kommen die in der Zahl, weil sie total ungeduldig werden und dann kann man einfach einen langen Ball drüber chippen und los geht's. Das ist dann so die Schwäche auf der defensiven Seite, dass die manchmal einfach die Nerven verlieren. Und auch innerhalb eines Spiels, das total dominiert wird, also Brentford ist so ein Beispiel, das haben sie total wirklich dominiert. Da hat Cole Palmer alleine 80 Prozent Spielanteile gehabt und dann passiert ein Fehler, ein Konter und der ist drin. Und ab dem Zeitpunkt verlieren die 30 Minuten komplett das Konzept. Das würde ich wiederum der Jugend zuschreiben und der relativen Unerfahrenheit zusammen. Und das sind, glaube ich, die zwei wesentlichen Punkte, plus ein Torhüter, der ist der Einzige aus dem Kader, den ich überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen kann, weil der dir keine Spiele gewinnt. Im Gegenteil, der verliert sogar manchmal welche in Robert Sanches. Das raffe ich nicht ganz, warum sie den verpflichtet haben, wohingegen sie überall Elite-Talent haben. Aber vielleicht denken sie sich irgendwas dabei. Der Torwart-Trainer kommt von Brighton, so wie der Rest des Staffs auch, bei Chelsea ist so ein Best-of aus Leipzig, Salzburg und Brighton. Und dieser Typ hat wohl bei Ekbali vorgeschlagen, dass man Robert Sanches holen könnte. Und Ekbali hört dann gerne mal zu, wenn er gute Laune hat.
Na ja, okay, gut. Aber sie müssen ja noch irgendwas haben, wo man noch weiteres Geld reinpumpen kann. Also Chelsea auf jeden Fall besser als der Tabellenplatz. Expected Goals werden hier natürlich hochgehalten im Rasenfunk. Und dann gucken wir doch mal, ob sich das wieder angleicht an Expected Goals zu den Ergebnissen. Aktuell Platz 10 mit eben 12 Punkten Rückstand auf die absolute Spitze. Wobei ja schon die ersten 5 Plätze wahrscheinlich schon ein Zwischenerfolg wären für Chelsea. Dann wollen wir nach Italien gucken und da können wir feststellen, Christian, dass Alec Broadwin neuer und alter Trainer von Napoli geworden ist.
Ja, Napoli wird so langsam zum monothematischen... Also das Italo-Segment des Rasenfunks wird zum Napoli im monothematischen Kanal. Ja, Rudi Garcia ist erlöst. Ich würde mal sagen, wir bringen es auf den Punkt seit wenigen Tagen. Die Entlassung jetzt in der Länderspielpause. Napoli hat das letzte Heimspiel gegen Empoli 0-1 verloren und damit war eigentlich klar, dass das Ding jetzt zu Ende ist. Ich sage bewusst, Rudi Garcia ist erlöst, weil ja, er hat Fehler gemacht, keine Frage, aber all das, was jetzt auf ihm abgeladen wird, entspricht eigentlich nicht der Situation, denn eigentlich müsste man viel mehr über Aurelio de Laurentiis sprechen, den Präsidenten, denn das war ja auch der, der Rudi Garcia im Sommer ausgewählt hat, der jetzt vor wenigen Wochen auch durch seine Äußerungen des Feuers selbst entzündet hat, dass Garcia halt auch in eine Ecke gedrängt hat, aus der er schwer rausgekommen ist. Garcia stand im Prinzip schon seit Sommer mehr oder weniger alleine da. Es gibt ja auch, vielleicht erinnern sich noch ein paar daran, es ist ja nicht nur Spalletti bei Napoli weg, sondern auch Giuntoli, der Sportdirektor, also der starke Mann, der das ganze Konstrukt halt auch geführt hat. Und da ist ein riesen Vakuum entstanden, das Aurelio de Larentes gedacht hat, das füllt er einfach mal selbst alleine aus. Da schließt sich der Kreis Richtung Alexis, was für einen Marseille betrifft. Da ist ein Präsident am Gange, der ja, hin und wieder mal denkt, dass er mehr oder weniger jede Rolle übernehmen kann. Und ja, jetzt sind wir halt eben beim Punkt. Auch da kleiner Querverweis zu Marseille. Igor Tudor war eigentlich jetzt der erste Kandidat, mit dem es auch die ersten Gespräche gab. Aber Igor Tudor hat sich dann wohl nicht in der Lage gesehen, nur einen Vertrag bis Saisonende zu unterschreiben. Weil das war jetzt wohl die Idee von de Laurentes, dass er erstmal einen hat, der durch die Saison führt, um ihm dann womöglich im Sommer halt auch neue Optionen zu geben. Und deswegen sind die Gespräche mit Tudor, der eigentlich ganz klar der heiße Favorit war, dann ja geändert. Eigentlich deutete vieles darauf hin, dass es Tudor wird. Und jetzt ist Walter Mazzarri. Jetzt werden Sie vielleicht ein paar denken, Walter Mazzarri. Der war vor 10 Jahren schon mal in Neapel und hat da wirklich eine sehr, sehr positive Wende eingeleitet. Da erinnern Sie sich vielleicht noch ein paar. Da gab es das Trio Hamschik-Kavani-Lavezzi. Das war unter ihm? Dann kenne ich ihn ja doch. Allein wer mit Ezekiel Lavezzi gut gearbeitet hat, ist eigentlich ein guter Mann, würde ich dazu sagen. Er hat eine schöne Geschichte da in Gang gebracht. Da ging auch dieser ganze Napoli-Rhythmus eigentlich los, der später zu dem geführt hat, was Napoli letzte Saison gekrönt hat mit dem Meistertitel. Ganz spannend übrigens auch zu Mazzarri. Mazzarri war mittlerweile in Europa die Dreierkette. Landauf, landab etabliert. Mazzarri war damals wirklich vor zehn Jahren mehr oder weniger der Erste, der das auch in der Serie etabliert hat, wo es ja dann auch in ganz Europa später ausgestrahlt hat. Die letzten Jahre waren aber bei Mazzarri ziemlich, sage ich mal, nicht mehr so spektakulär. War jetzt auch ein Jahr komplett raus, war zuletzt in Kaljeri. Da hat es überhaupt nicht funktioniert. Davor war es Torino oder Uli. Erinnert sich vielleicht noch an seine What-for-Zeit. Die war jetzt auch nicht weiß Gott wie prickelnd. Aber es ist ganz spannend, weil Mazzarri einfach einen heißen Draht zu Neapel hat und das Umfeld, den jetzt sehr, sehr positiv willkommen heißt. Weil er eben schon da war, weil er das Umfeld kennt und weil er einer ist, der, und das haben jetzt schon diese ersten, er hat jetzt glaube ich am Dienstag erste Training geleitet, weil er etwas verkörpert, was dieser Mannschaft eigentlich genau gefehlt hat, nämlich die Intensität. Wir denken ja, wenn wir uns an Neapel letzte Saison erinnern, klar, dann denken viele an Oseman, Quaratzkelia, zu Recht, den tollen Fußball. Aber der tolle Fußball hatte darauf basiert, dass die sehr intensiv gespielt haben. Also nicht nur mit Ball, sondern auch gegen den Ball. Und zuletzt muss man sagen, Garcia hat es emotional einfach nicht geschafft, dieser Mannschaft Energie zu vermitteln. Diese Mannschaft hat manchmal ganz platt gewirkt. Das sind auch ein paar Spieler, muss man auch ganz klar sagen, um wieder die Schuld weg von Garcia zu nehmen. Das spielen auch ein paar Spieler komplett unter ihrem Niveau. Für mich, der, der da raussticht, ist leider Anguissa. Anguissa ist einer der letzte Saison, der ist mit breiter Brust, der hat alle weggeschoben, die in seiner Nähe waren. Und diese Saison, überspitzt gesagt, spazierte er manchmal übers Feld. Und genau diese Intensität, die braucht Napoli wieder. Und in Neapel trauen sie es eben, Walter Mazzarri mit seiner energischen Art, aber in positiven, zu das wieder reinzubringen. Mazzarri hat jetzt vor dem ersten Training gesagt, er hat drei Nächte lang nicht geschlafen, vor lauter Aufregung, aber auch vor lauter Vorbereitung.
Da stehen die Napolitane irgendwie drauf, oder? Bei Spalletti war es ja auch schon, Mensch, toll, der kommt manchmal gar nicht mehr nachts nach Hause, weil er so viel arbeitet.
Ja, klar, das kann man jetzt belächeln, aber ich glaube schon, dass das vielleicht etwas ist. Wenn er das zumindest schafft, der Mannschaft zu geben, dann ist das jetzt, glaube ich, mal was Gutes, weil der Kader ist immer noch, bis auf Kim, der aus der letzten Saison. Ociment kommt jetzt auch wieder nach der Länderspielpause zurück, weil wieder wochenlang verletzt. Also er hat schon Material, mit dem er arbeiten kann. Aber nochmal, um auf De Laurentis die Klammer zu schließen, ganz klar ist, das war jetzt der zweite Versuch von De Laurentis in dieser Saison und der muss jetzt sitzen. Denn, wenn wir uns die Tabelle anschauen, bei Napoli hat niemand erwartet, dass die jetzt noch mal gemütlich ein zweites Jahr in Folge den Meistertitel holen. Das ist überhaupt nicht das Thema. Aber in der Serie A ist es mehr als schwer genug, sich überhaupt für die Top 4 zu qualifizieren. Wenn man sich ja auch die letzte Saison schon angeschaut hat, also die Dichte ist sehr hoch. Inter kannst du komplett rausnehmen. Also ein Platz ist tausendprozentig schon vergeben. Der zweite deutet sehr viel darauf hin, dass sie sich Juve schnappt, weil sie sehr stabil sind, weil sie nicht die Doppelbelastung haben. So, dann hast du noch zwei Plätze übrig. Und das sage ich mal, Napoli, Milan, Roma, Lazio und Atalanta würde ich da auch mit reinnehmen. Also es ist schwierig genug, quasi die Top 4 wieder zu erreichen. Und in der Champions League ist logisch das Minimalziel jetzt das Achtelfinale. Da stehen sie auch gut da. Und dementsprechend geht es jetzt darum, für Mazzarri das sozusagen in die Wege zu leiten. Und dann schauen wir mal, was der Laurentis nächsten Sommer wieder für Ideen hat. Vielleicht kann sich ja Mazzarri beweisen. Der Name Antonio Conte, nur zum Abschluss, war auch jetzt wieder ein Thema. Der Laurentis hat sich wieder bei Conte gemeldet, der aber nochmal gesagt, er steigt nicht während der Saison ein. Vielleicht ist das ja auch die Idee dahinter, dann Richtung nächsten Sommer vielleicht nochmal eine andere Lösung zu präsentieren.
Jetzt hat man auf jeden Fall eine Legende zurück. Walter Mazzarri. Es gibt nur drei Trainer, die mehr Spiele mit Napoli gemacht haben. Die ersten beiden davon, das war irgendwann in den 40ern und 20ern des letzten Jahrhunderts. Und auf Rang 3 hat er sich schon in 4 Pflichtspielen geschoben. Das wird er hoffentlich schaffen. Und dann ist er quasi der längste Trainer der Neuzeit. Uli möchte sich einmischen oder er ist sich nicht ganz sicher? Ich war nicht, ob das gerade ein Melden war.
Also mein Wissen ist ja Christian sozusagen. Nur in meinen Worten, weil ich ihn immer genervt habe vor den Champions-League-Spielen zu Neapel. Also alles, was ich so von De Laurentis weiß, ist das man nie weiß.
Ja, das trifft es perfekt, Uli. Bis vor eineinhalb Tagen ist jeder davon ausgegangen, dass Tudor es wird. Es war über Nacht eigentlich schon so gut wie fix. Tudor war schon in Rom, hat mit De Laurentis verhandelt. Plötzlich, am nächsten Tag, springt Mazzarri hervor. Das ist wirklich De Laurentis. Den Mann kannst du nicht berechnen. Und er hat wirklich die komplette Kontrolle. Also alles, was da passiert, entscheidet Aurelia De Laurentis. Und jetzt muss er zeigen, dass er über die letzten Jahre sehr viel richtig gemacht hat. Das darf man ja auch nicht vergessen. Napoli steht ja auch da, weil er das ja auch möglich gemacht hat. Aber da hat er auch sehr gute Leute gehabt. Und gerade, das passt auch wieder zum Thema OM noch mal als Abschluss, dieses Vakuum ohne starken Sportdirektor, das ist halt ein großes Problem. Also es ist kein Zufall, dass die meisten großen Vereine einen starken Sportdirektor haben. Es geht halt auch zwischen Vereinsführung, zwischen Mannschaft, das ganze Klima zu organisieren, zu managen. Und da war Giuntoli halt auch ein ganz, ganz, ganz wichtiger Mann. Alle haben immer gesagt, oh das Ballett ist weg. Ja, aber Giuntoli ist eben auch weg. Und wenn dann einer wie die Laurentis meint, er kann das alles alleine machen, dann hat er spätestens jetzt Mitte November gemerkt, dass jetzt erst mal der erste Versuch nicht geklappt hat.
Aber schon erstaunlich, ein Vierteljahr plus nach der Meisterschaft, dass das schon fast zu den Flammen steht. Also es scheint auch dazu zu gehören da, aber ich finde es trotzdem erstaunlich.
Ja gut, aber es war ja damals schon, wir haben es ja quasi in der letzten Saison schon anmoderiert, mit der Meisterfeier, dass man schon sehen konnte, ja, jetzt geht es schon wieder dahin. Aber gut, immerhin hat es ja zu der einen Meisterschaft gereicht. Und die große Frage ist natürlich, wenn wir auf die Ligue 1 nochmal blicken, wird es denn auch PSG schaffen, nochmal Meister zu werden? Und ich kann euch beruhigen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, es sieht ganz gut aus. Erst eine Niederlage nach 12 Spielen, 27 Punkte, auch wenn Nizza immer noch PSG ziemlich am Hintern hängt. Und über Nizza haben wir ja auch zuletzt gesprochen in der Ligatur. Aber Alexi, du möchtest über Luis Enrique reden. Warum? Was gibt es denn bei PSG? Ist denn nicht gerade alles wunderbar?
Stimmt, der Schlemmästige können sie zum ersten Mal in der Gummephase ausscheiden. Das war natürlich ein Erdbeben am 13. Dezember, wenn es gegen den dauernden deutschen Vizemeister schieflaufen sollte. Luis Enrique macht, sagen wir mal, die Wissen, und das kann Luis bestimmt bestätigen, er hasst Journalisten. Und in Paris hat er ein paar Stunden nur gebraucht, um das zu zeigen. Es hat angefangen so konkret nach der Niederlage in Newcastle 4-1, wo er alles fantastisch fand, im Gegensatz zu allen, die das Spiel gesehen haben, wo Paris vor einem zweiten Durchgang komplett geschwommen ist und vielleicht unterging im Regen von St. James Park. Und er sagt immer das Gegenteil von dem, was wir sehen. Und das ist einfach eine Provokation. Es gab auch zuletzt die Tatsache, dass er Glenn Mbappe kritisiert hat, nachdem der Franzose drei Tore erzielt hat. Das war natürlich taktisch, weil er traut sich genau wenig, wie seine Vorgänger Tuchel, Emery, Galtier, Procettino Mbappe zu kritisieren, wenn Mbappe schlecht gespielt hat. Das war clever von ihm, er hat ein Spiel ausgewählt, eine Leistung, wo alles gepasst hat. Aber es stimmt auch, dass Mbappe seit dem Sommer nicht mehr der Mbappe ist, den wir kennen. Auch wenn seine Feinde, Messi und Neymar, nicht mehr da sind, trotzdem ist er im Topf woanders. Wir wissen noch nicht, wo, aber er scheint nicht wirklich geriert zu sein.
Nils hat das Gefühl, es ist zu wissen, wo er ist.
Und wir wissen nicht, was er eigentlich mit seiner Kommunikation und mit seiner Außendarstellung will. Er soll schon viel für Irritationen und es ist schon sehr lange her, wo man bei Pressekonferenzen in Paris Unterhaltung hatte. Und das war zuletzt einfach Thomas Tuchel, der das Spiel mitgespielt hat, der ehrlich war, der einfach für die französischen und PSG-Journalisten ein Traum war, weil alle seine Nachfolger sind eine Katastrophe. Und Lucien Ricke ist auch nicht besser in dieser Hinsicht. Zuletzt hat er sich auch angelegt vor den laufenden Kameras mit einem Kollegen, weil er einfach keine Lust mehr hatte, eine von fünf negative Fragen zu beantworten. Also schon vergleichbar mit Tuchel gegen Didi und Lothar.
Schön. Kaum ist Alexi da, muss ich nicht mehr die Bundesliga-Bezüge herstellen. Das ist sehr traumhaft. Wunderbar, das war so der Running-Gag der letzten Sendung, Alexi, dass ich immer wieder ganz, ganz naheliegende Vergleiche zur Bundesliga gewählt habe, zur Veranschaulichung. Ich sehe schon. Und ich meine, gut, klar, das, was du mit der Champions League gesagt hast, das ergibt natürlich Sinn. Man hat gegen Newcastle verloren, auswärts. Man hat gegen Milan auswärts verloren. Aber man hat ja noch beide Heimspiele und dann halt noch auswärts beim BVB, der dann ja wahrscheinlich schon sicher durch ist, was wir ja alle genauso erwartet haben vor wenigen Wochen. Naja, also, aber interessant, was du erzählt hast zur Kommunikation von Luis Enrique. Kriegt man fast Lust, ein paar PKs zu gucken. Das ist ja irgendwie, wenn man nicht im Raum sitzt mit ihm und die Fragen stellt, dann könnte das ja sogar ganz interessant sein. Und wer hätte gedacht, dass wir hier nochmal über Thomas Tuchel in dieser Art und Weise zumindest sprechen. Dann blicken wir nochmal nach Spanien, Nils. Und da wollen wir nochmal uns auseinandersetzen mit Viareal. Die hast du vorhin schon mal kurz erwähnt, wenn ich mich nicht komplett täusche. Oder habe ich sie... Naja, auf jeden Fall habe ich vorhin an Viareal gedacht. Vielleicht liegt es auch nur daran. Was ist denn zu denen zu sagen?
Seine Gedanken sind berechtigt. Man muss sich fast ein bisschen Sorgen machen. Denn wenn wir so auf die jüngere Vergangenheit Viareal zurückschauen, wir erinnern uns Europa League Sieg 2021. Dann ein Jahr später die Bayern in der Champions League rausgeworfen. Ja, und seitdem ist viel passiert. Unter anderem auch ein paar gute Spieler sind weggegangen. Uli hat eben Nico Jackson angesprochen. Der hat zu den Spielern gehört, die man im Sommer in Geld umgemünzt hat. Auch Paul Torres ist nach England gegangen, macht das dort sehr gut. Samu Chokuezi ist weg. Und jetzt auf einmal merkt der Verein Hoppler, irgendwie, da fehlen ein paar gute Spieler. Und wie kriegt man das jetzt noch hin? Ja, prompt ist man Platz 14. Das klingt nicht so schlimm. Aber es ist aktuell mit 12 Pünktchen, ist es die schwächste La-Liga-Saison, die der FC Viareal bisher gespielt hat. Die sind noch nicht so ewig dabei in La Liga. Aber das ist schon mal besorgniserregend. Deswegen ist jetzt auf einmal der 3. Trainer der Saison da. Da gab es jetzt frischen Trainerwechsel. Also man ist ja mit Kike Setien in die Saison gestartet. Der hatte ja für Una Emery übernommen, der auch zu Villa gegangen ist. Und das war immer so, okay, die Ergebnisse stimmten mal nicht. So richtig die Kabine hatte er nicht. Es gab immer mal ein paar Problemchen. Dann kam vor 12 wettbewerbsübergreifenden Spielen Paceta. Das war ein Trainer, der bisher nur Abstiegskandidaten trainiert hatte, noch nie international vertreten war. Also war da Villareal vielleicht ein bisschen eine Nummer zu groß, obwohl er eigentlich ein ganz netter, freundlicher Typ ist. Und jetzt kommt es zu einem Comeback. Marcelino ist zurück. Der hatte Villareal vor einigen Jahren von der 2. in die 1. Liga geführt und dann auch direkt für Europapokal qualifiziert. Also ist dort sowohl ein großer Name in Spanien, als auch ein emotionaler Bezug zum Verein. Das Wort Rettung wird jetzt nicht verwendet, aber es sieht schon ein bisschen bedrohlich aus, weil eigentlich hat die Mannschaft immer noch ein paar gute Spieler. Zerlot funktioniert, den haben sie sich geholt. Gera Moreno macht seine Tore, die sind unter den beiden in den Top 10 der Torjäger in der Liga dabei. Aber irgendwie ein bisschen veraltet, wenig Talente. Paul Torres war das letzte große Talent, was der Verein hervorgebracht hat, der ist weg. Jeremy Pino funktioniert noch nicht so, wurde jetzt auch nicht für die Nationalmannschaft berufen. Also muss da der neue Trainer Marcelino schauen, wie er aus einer Truppe mit ein paar ordentlichen guten Kickern noch wieder eine richtig gute Mannschaft zusammenschweißen kann. Das ist so, glaube ich, eine ganz große Herausforderung.
Und jetzt weiß ich nämlich auch, warum ich an VR real gedacht habe. Weil das war natürlich im Marseille-Segment. Da hat doch Alexi Marcelino schon erwähnt. Deswegen habe ich mich selber gewundert, wo kam der VR-Realbezug her. Aber das war es natürlich. Aber welchen Anspruch hat denn eigentlich VR real? Also, dass man natürlich gerne besser wäre, weil man in der Vergangenheit besser war, das ist ja völlig klar. Aber du kannst ja auch nicht im jeden Jahr Bayern aus der Champions-League werfen. Triffst ja gar nicht immer auf sie. Das ist natürlich das größte Problem dabei. Aber wo sieht sich VR real? Wo sollten die eigentlich stehen?
Das ist so ein bisschen diese Identifikationsfrage, die man, glaube ich, im Verein hat. Man ist ein sehr kleiner Verein aus einer sehr kleinen Stadt. Noch nicht so viel in der Liga gespielt. Vielleicht 20 Saisons immerhin. Aber jetzt vielleicht in zu kurzer Zeit zu groß geworden. Also zu schnell groß geworden mit Europa League und Champions League hier. Man hat jetzt nicht, wie vielleicht Union Berlin gleich, mega viele Topstars eingekauft. Die funktionieren nicht zusammen, dass man da Saisonvorbereitung-Fehler gemacht hat. Aber irgendwie einfach zu viel Kasse gemacht im Sommer, aber dann doch zu wenig ausgegeben fast. Oder eben die Mannschaft funktioniert nicht mehr so. Was ist das Ziel? Man will schon europäisch bleiben, weil man dann doch irgendwo seinen Kerl aufgebläht hat. Und ob das ein Dani Parejo ist oder Cera Moreno aus Söhrloth, die ja auch ein gewisses Gehalt haben. Also international sollte es schon wieder sein. Letztes Jahr haben sie Conference League gespielt. Und da hatte eigentlich keiner so richtig Lust drauf. Im Verein ist man ja auch früh schon ausgeschieden. Also Europa League ist da glaube ich schon irgendwo das interne Ziel. Aber das ist weit weg. Und oben hat man schon irgendwie 5, 6, 7 Teams, die da sehr stabil mittlerweile spielen. Ob das auch der Athletik-Club ist oder Bts. Deswegen wird das schon schwierig. Gibt vieles an was man arbeiten kann. Dass man das Team ist, das die meisten Abschlüsse in der Liga kassiert, durchschnittlich 16. Daran kann man arbeiten. Aber dass man das älteste Team der Liga ist, gemeinsam mit Atletico im Schnitt fast 29 Jahre alt, der Kader, daran lässt sich schwierig arbeiten. Also muss man sehen, wohin das geht. Marcelino soll da einfach wieder für Stabilität sorgen. Hat ja ein ganz kurzes Intermezzo bei Marseille gehabt. Und soll da vielleicht auch wieder Spaß haben an der Arbeit. Seine letzte Station beim Atleti-Club war auch nicht so schön erfolgreich, auch wenn er die Super-Kopper gewonnen hat. Aber da ist für ihn auch wieder so ein kleines Feel-Good-Becken, wo er mal wieder vielleicht Spaß haben kann an der Arbeit.
Ein Feel-Good-Becken. Und es kann ja auch mit einem alten Kader funktionieren. In der Folge, die wir zur Coppa Libertadores aufgenommen haben, da haben wir das herausgearbeitet. Mit dem südamerikanischen Fußball ganz, ganz andere Herangehensweise an die Kader-Zusammenstellung, da ist es eben nicht ungewöhnlich, dass dann so ein gefühlt 58-jähriger Marcello noch rumläuft, sondern da gehört das eben mit dazu. Und jetzt gerade in Argentinien im Abschiegskampf stecken die jüngsten Teams der Liga. Hat mir jetzt Andreas Galpin neutig nochmal geschickt. Konnte ich das hier sogar noch unterbringen? Hätte ich nicht gedacht. Sehr schön. Danke, wie er real, danke, Nils. Und jetzt wissen wir, Uli bringt immer ein schönes und ein trauriges Thema mit. Das traurige Thema, das ist der FC Burnley. Und wenn sich alle fragen, was ist denn daran traurig, dann sage ich 12 Spiele, 4 Punkte, 30 Gegentore. Reicht das schon, um das zu beschreiben, Uli?
Nein, das ist noch nie mal das Schlimmste. Also, okay, alle drei Aufsteiger sind unten. Das war fast, na eben nicht. Das war eben nicht ganz so zu erwarten, sondern ich hab bei Burnley gedacht, die sind als absolute Stil-Ikonen aufgestiegen in die Premier League. Und Kompany galt so als der sichere Gordiola-Nachfolger. Und völlig zurecht, weil der Typ überragenden Fußball spielen ließ in Liga 2, weil der auch im Pokalwettbewerb mit Citi mitgehalten hat. 30, 35 Minuten. Und weil er vor allen Dingen kommunikativ, ich hab selten spannendere Interviews gehört, Einschätzungen gehört. Der hat so das Fußballs Kobe Bryant sozusagen, also der Erfolgswille auf zwei Beinen. Und das habe ich immer sehr, sehr genossen, dem zuzuhören überdurchschnittlich intelligenter Typ. Und das Problem ist, dass die jetzt in die Premier League kommen und nur noch Plan B anwenden. Also der ist total eingeknickt und spielt jetzt anstatt des mannorientierten Pressings, das er in der zweiten Liga hat spielen lassen, dass die permanent dem Gegner alles angehängt haben, mit zwei inverted Außenverteidigern gespielt haben und dann sozusagen darüber mit wahnsinnig viel Ballbesitz auf schnelle, auf athletische, aber vor allen Dingen raffinierte Offensivspieler zu kommen, spielt er jetzt ein ganz hässliches 4-1-4-1 und fast schon passiv. Und ich sage das ja immer wieder an der Stelle, ich glaube nach wie vor, dass du in der Premier League ohne aggressive Presse nichts holst, gar nichts holst. Und deswegen sind wir auf dem letzten Platz, so einfach ist die Erklärung. Ich bin maximal enttäuscht von Kompany, der total einbricht und sogar, wir haben noch keine Trainerentlassungen in der Premier League in der Saison, was auch total erstaunlich ist, aber sogar kurz vor der Entlassung zu stehen scheint, weil Burnley, ja auch amerikanisch geführt, durchaus ein sehr ambitioniertes Projekt ist. Kompany durfte sich komplett verwirklichen auf dem Transfermarkt. Sieht man daran, dass er aus seiner Belgien-Zeit fast alle Spieler mitgenommen hat, also entweder die, die damals in der Liga gespielt haben oder die, die er damals schon hatte. Und er hat sich eigentlich auch Spieler geholt, die für mich total passig sind. Also ja, die sind jung. Das ist, glaube ich, der Schutz, den man ihnen noch geben kann. Aber alles samt Spieler, die eigentlich ins alte System passen. Und jetzt fällt er so um und hat aber auch null Erfolg damit. Und das enttäuscht mich maximal. Also ich habe gehofft oder gedacht, dass das so Leads-Vibes geben könnte, wie damals unter Bielsa, dass die einfach aufräumen mit der Liga. Und vielleicht sogar auf 9 bis 13 oder so gehen können. Aber vor allen Dingen die Art und Weise uns Mut macht. Und Kompany dann halt irgendwann mal weiterziehen wird, weil es nicht anders geht. Aber dass das so jetzt wird, dass... Also ich bin kein Trainer, deswegen kann ich das schwierig nachvollziehen. Aber wenn ich Kompany treffen würde, würde ich ihm sagen, komm, was ist los? Ich habe mich sehr gefreut auf dich.
Okay, aber wir merken uns auf jeden Fall. Also sollte Kompany wirklich entlassen werden, immer wenn irgendein Coach zurücktritt oder entlassen wird in der Bundesliga, werden immer dieselben drei Namen genannt. Und ich kann Andre Breitenreiters Name nicht mehr hören. Nichts gegen ihn persönlich. Aber ich möchte das nicht mehr. Ich möchte auch nicht mehr Markus Gister holen. Ich möchte ab jetzt immer dann solche Vorschläge haben. Vincent Kompany, das wäre doch wunderschön. Kann er nicht mit dem HSV auch aufsteigen? Wäre das nicht die Geschichte eigentlich? Wahrscheinlich ist er schon zu groß dafür. Na ja.
Wolfsburg. Step forward. Ich weiß nicht, das wird passieren. Aber erst Jesse Marsch. Erst wird da Jesse Marsch hingehen und dann wird es Kompany.
Bei Wolfsburg jetzt?
Ja, ja. Ich kann dir nicht sagen warum, aber wenn die irgendwann noch mal einen Trainer suchen, dann wird es Jesse Marsch. Das habe ich einfach im Urin.
Okay, du solltest zu einem Arzt gehen. Niemand außerhalb der Wolfsburg-Blaze sollte irgendwas zum VfL Wolfsburg in seinem Urin haben. Aber das ist eine komplett andere Thematik. Vielleicht können sie ja auch tauschen. So wie Burnley aktuell spielt, könnte da Niko Kovac super hin. Das scheint wunderbar zu passen. Ja, okay, muss ich dir geben. Wir haben noch die Serie A. Wir haben noch die Serie A. Und da weiß ich nicht auswendig, wo die liegen, muss nachgucken. Platz 12, 15 Punkte. 6 bzw. 5 Punkte hinter dem Europapokal. Und 6 Punkte auch dann tatsächlich vor der Abstiegszone. Was ist denn zu Frosinone so bemerkenswert? Was ist denn zu Frosinone so bemerkenswert?
Genau, das ist der Punkt, die 6-Punkte-Abstand zur Abstiegszone. Denn Frosinone als Aufsteiger galt vor der Saison mehr oder weniger in allen Kreisen als der Abstiegskandidat Nr. Es lag daran, dass viele wichtige Spiele abgegeben wurden. Fabio Grosso, der mittlerweile in Frankreich ist, der Aufstiegstrainer, hat dann auch gesagt, er macht nicht weiter. Mit Eusebio de Francesco ein Trainer kam, der in den letzten Jahren überhaupt nicht funktioniert hat. Dementsprechend haben mehr oder weniger alle nur darauf gewartet, dass Frosinone da hinten drin kleben bleibt und das Ganze so läuft, wie es läuft. Aber, wie du eben angesprochen hast, sie haben mittlerweile schon 6-Punkte-Vorsprung auf dem Abstiegszone. Sie haben nur 2-Punkte weniger als Lazio geholt, nur mal das um das einzuordnen. Und, jetzt haben wir viel über Zahlen geredet, sie spielen einen richtig feinen Ball und sie haben einen Kader, der unfassbar spannend ist. Denn, als es im Sommer losging mit diesem ganzen, okay, Frosinone geht sicher runter, das war kurz vor Saisonstart und da hatten sie noch nichts von dem gemacht, wie sie jetzt da stehen. Und das Besondere ist, das ist ein Kader, der hat zuletzt einen Altersschnitt von 22,9 gehabt, also da gehen wir fast in Richtung Salzburg-Kategorie. Und da spielen Leihspieler von Juve, Real Madrid, dem FC Bayern und Atalanta. Also, die haben ein Konzept gefunden, dass die ganz spät im Sommer sich sehr talentierte, junge, entwicklungsfähige Leute geliehen haben. Fangen wir mal mit Juve an, weil da sind es gleich drei, das sind nämlich Barinecea, junger defensiver Mittelfeldspieler, Stéa Soleil, auf den kommen wir noch, Argentinier, und Caio Georges, auch ein sehr talentierter Angreifer, der ein Jahr lang verletzt war, aber in den Juve einiges investiert hat. Von Bayern kam der junge Ibrahimovic, also nicht der Ibrahimovic, aber Aion Ibrahimovic. Marvin Cuni war bei Bayern 2, war vergangenes Saison an Saarbrücken ausgeliehen, spielt jetzt vorne im Sturm. Von Real kam Ranier, den vielleicht auch einige noch aus seiner Dortmund-Zeit in Erinnerung haben. Und von Atalanta kam Okoli, U21-Nationalspieler Italiens Innenverteidiger. Und man muss sagen, diese Mannschaft spielt genauso, wie sie nämlich, was ihr Altersnachweis hergibt, sehr jung, sehr erfrischend. Also das ist ein 4-2-3-1, teilweise auch 4-3-3. Da wird aktiv, da wird Fußball gespielt. Matthias Sole ist wirklich der herausragende Akteur. Argentinier, offensiver außen, 5 Tore schon, 5 Großchanzen herausgespielt. Nur mal dazu, dass die Spieler mit dem Abstand am meisten gewonnenen Dribbling sind. Mehr als vier pro Spiel im Schnitt. Damit doppelt so viele wie die Quaratskelias und Leaus dieser Welt. Also nur um das mal einzuordnen. Also der Juveplan ist da perfekt aufgegangen. Der hat in den letzten ein, zwei Jahren bei Juve schon immer mal aufplitzen lassen, dass das ein großes Talent ist. Und jetzt kriegt er einfach jede Woche hat er seinen Einsatz. Trainiert auch dementsprechend intensiver und ist wirklich im Moment einer der aufregendsten Spieler der Serie A. Also wirklich großartig dem zuzuschauen. Ist jetzt nicht so ein Tempo-Dribbler wie Leao oder so, aber so eher der schlagsige Typ, so ein bisschen die Maria mäßig war ja auch bei Juve, als die Maria da war. Die Ballast hat auch immer sein großes Vorbild. Mit dem hat er ja auch bei Juve trainiert. Also ein ganz, ganz, ganz spannender Spieler. Und wie gesagt, der zusammen mit den Reniers, mit den Okolis, funktioniert wunderbar. Und deswegen steht Frosinone eben so gut da, was niemand gedacht hätte. Und da muss man jetzt auch nochmal eine Lanze für Eusebio Di Francesco brechen. Ich hab den auch vor dem Saisonstart, dachte ich mir, okay, das wird nicht funktionieren, weil die letzten seiner Auftritte bei Hellas und so, die waren katastrophal. Aber er war jetzt eine Zeit lang raus, war 2 Jahre lang raus und hat auch selbst vor der Saison gesagt, er hat so die Liebe, die Lust am Fußball wieder gefunden, hat selbst gesagt, mehrere Enkel sind jetzt bei ihm da gekommen, hat viel mit den Jungs, das klingt jetzt vielleicht auch so ein bisschen kindlich, aber ich kann es mir mittlerweile gut vorstellen. Er hat gesagt, er hat wirklich über seine Enkel, über seine Enkelsöhne so ein bisschen die Lust am Fußball wieder bekommen und jetzt sorgt er dafür, dass diese Mannschaft diesen spannenden Stil spielt, die immer mitspielt. Kurz vor der Länderspielpause waren sie bei Inter zu Gast, haben da zwar 2-0 verloren, haben aber auch mitgespielt, haben nach dem 0-2 Inter Probleme bereitet, hätten es 1-2 machen können und deswegen die Francesco, an den sie vielleicht noch ein paar erinnern. Der war damals der Roma-Trainer, der die Roma ins Champions League-Halbfinale geführt hat, wo sie dieses legendäre Barca nach dem 1-3-Hinspiel, das 3-0 im Rückspiel, dann auch im Halbfinale knapp nur an Liverpool gescheitert. Das waren die Roma mit Salah, mit Alisson, mit Rossi. In den Jahren danach wurde es um die Francesco sehr ruhig, aber jetzt scheint er anscheinend in dem Umfeld wieder da gelandet zu sein, was ihm gut tut, was der Mannschaft gut tut. Das ist wirklich eine schöne Geschichte.
Stark, sehr schön. Habe ich alles überhaupt nicht mitbekommen.
Man hat, glaube ich, Frosinone nicht unbedingt auf der Karte. Dementsprechend, wie hat es Nils vorhin gesagt, eine vielgut Geschichte, würde ich auch sagen.
Eine vielgut Geschichte. Die verstehen sich so gut, wahrscheinlich muss man sie Frosinone umbenennen. Und das ist noch der 40.
Dira auf der Bank.
Walid Cedira.
Das ist ein spannender Kader.
Der beste Zweitligaspieler letztes Jahr, so ein marokkanischer Nationalspiel. Der kommt im Moment fast gar nicht dran, weil eben da vorne diese talentierten Jungen im Prinzip noch besser sind. Und Caio Jorge hat jetzt erst die letzten Minuten gespielt. Da war wirklich ein komplettes Jahr lang bei Juve raus. Bei dem kommt wahrscheinlich auch noch was, weil für den hat Juve einiges an Geld in die Hand genommen. Den wollen sie auch mittelfristig aufbauen. Also da steckt immer noch Potenzial da. Und letzter Punkt zu Soleil. Wirklich schaut ihn euch mal an. Luciano Spalletti war vor kurzem in Frosinone und hat mal mit ihm geredet, weil er italienische Vorfahren hat. Aber Soleil hat ihm wohl gesagt, er ist Argentiner Rojontur. Matteo Soleil war schon im Kreis der Argentinischen Nationalmannschaft. Der wird sehr bald sein Debüt auch feiern, dass er für Argentinien festgespielt ist.
Stark! Also den haben wir jetzt auf jeden Fall im Blick. Aber damit sind wir ja direkt bei dem Segment gelandet, wo es eben um die Frage geht, wen müssen wir denn im Blick haben? Wir wollen noch unsere Awards vergeben. MVP, Unsung Hero und Moment der Woche des Spieltags, was euch eben so im Blick geblieben ist. Nils ist wie immer sehr gut vorbereitet. Deswegen darf er jetzt mal vorlegen. Nils, wer ist dein MVP der aktuellen Phase?
Ja, vor allem des letzten Spieltags war das eine klare Sache. Da hat ein Spieler vier Torbeteiligungen gemacht. Weil seine Mannschaft hat 5-1 gewonnen. Das erste Tor hat er auch noch durch den Laufweg mit eingeleitet. Also Rodrigo Goisch hat dann eine besondere Geschichte geschrieben gegen den FC Valencia, weil er auch davor, ich glaube, über 40 Abschlüsse gegen Nijmaiereien. Und viele Fans haben sich gefragt, warum darf der immer noch spielen? Ancelotti hat ihm vertraut. Und Rodrigo sagte selbst so nach dem Spiel, dass ich war nicht in meinem besten Moment, aber der Trainer war immer an meiner Seite. Und ich hatte das Gefühl, mit ihm zusammenzufeiern. So hat er dann nach dem Tor eben mit ihm gejubelt. Also das kleine, schöne Geschichte, dass bei ihm jetzt der Knoten geplatzt ist. Deswegen für mich so da der MVP.
Den kaufen wir so. Alexi, wer ist denn gerade so der MVP der Ligue 1? Komm jetzt nicht mit Mbappé, bitte.
Da ist ja kein Hochdungsträger, der schon reif genug ist, schon fast alt geworden. Warren Zahir Emry ist ein Mitspieler bei PSG, der 17 Jahre alt ist, bei PSG eine feste Größe. Der meist eingesetzte Spieler von unserem Freund Luis Narrique. Und der zum ersten Mal berufen worden in der französischen Nationalmannschaft. Er war schon im Oktober zum ersten Mal von Thierry Henry in der U21 berufen worden. Und dann hat ihm Henry sofort die Kapitängebinde gegeben. Das war schon ein Zeichen. Henry hat übrigens nichts mit Uwe Henry zu tun, nur so am Rande. Er ist schon sehr komplett, sehr reif in seinem Spiel, sehr selbstbewusst, aber auch bescheiden in seinem Auftreten. Also keine möglichen Tattoos oder Piercings überall. Nein, nein, er schaut geradeaus und weiß, was er will. Ich weiß nicht, wohin das führt. Er kann auch schon nach drei Jahren sagen, es ist mir alles zu viel. Aber wenn er so bleibt wie momentan, dann kann er sehr weit kommen. Und endlich haben es die Verantwortlichen von Paris Saint-Germain kapiert. Der darf nicht weg. Nicht so wie früher, Coman, Gunku, Diaby und so weiter. Er wird bleiben. Er wird auch langfristig verlängern demnächst. Und die künstliche Mannschaft soll um ihn aufgebaut werden. Wenn Mbappé zu Apollon Limas wechselt im kommenden Sommer, dann ist er der neue Chef. Und er soll wirklich sehr lange bleiben. Und wirklich eine Augenweite, wenn er spielt. Extrem effizient, extrem wichtig bei Peugeot und bald in der Nationalmannschaft.
Und wird daher auch einen Rekord ausstellen, oder? Könnte er jüngster Nationalspieler werden? Oder einer der jüngsten der letzten Jahre?
Nein, das ist leider Nils Eduardo Camariga geworden.
Ah, leider, das konnte man ihm ja auch sehr gönnen. Für mich sowieso einfach nur entscheidend, ob er auch eine Holding Six spielen kann. Das muss ich mir erstmal ganz in Ruhe nochmal angucken. Aber das ist ja sowieso für alle klar. Uli, wer ist dein MVP aktuell in der Premier League?
Also Mohamed Salah, honorable mention, ist wieder bei Altersstärke. Musa Diaby möchte ich auch noch nennen, aber einer, der gerade nicht spielt, und an dem sieht man, wie wichtig er ist, weil er eben nicht spielt. James Madison, hätte ich im Leben nicht damit gerechnet, dass der so, so, so stilgebend ist für Tottenham, dass der überhaupt effizient sein kann, hätte ich nicht gedacht. Also ich habe mir in meinen Notizen immer aufgeschrieben, das ist so eine Art Luxusspieler, den du dir leisten musst, aber das stimmt alles gar nicht, sondern der macht alles in der Offensive bei Tottenham. Und seit der nicht da ist, merkt man mal, wie wichtig der eigentlich ist und war, und der kommt von einem Absteiger. Das hätte ich also so alles nicht gesehen. Und seit der weg ist es tatsächlich so, dass Tottenham sehr, sehr, sehr viel leichter ausrechenbar ist. Deswegen muss man den einfach, glaube ich, nennen. Und ich habe jetzt einfach mal mir das zu Nutze gemacht und nehme jetzt mal die ersten 12 Spieltage und setze ihn da ziemlich klar an die Spitze aller Premier League-Spieler im Moment, was den Einfluss betrifft. Und ich weiß, man nimmt immer Salah und Harlan schon fast, und Rodri und wie sie alle heißen, for granted, wie man in England sagt, aber trotzdem Madison. Nicht nur des Überraschungsfaktors wegen, aber schon auch vor allen Dingen.
Stark, gute Wahl. Hätte ich nicht mit gerechnet. Christian, mit wem wirst du mich jetzt überraschen?
Ja, ist vielleicht ja vorne auch hängen geblieben. Wir gehen einfach mit Soleil. Auch aufgrund der letzten Wochen. Jetzt nicht nur aufgrund eines Spiels. Nur ein, zwei Sachen noch dazu. Bei ihm war es so ein bisschen so ein relativ, sage ich mal, ein schlagsiger, schlanker Spiel. Also da war immer die Frage Körperlichkeit. Und da hat er jetzt wirklich draufgepackt. Also hat immer noch diese Beweglichkeit. Aber hat jetzt einfach dadurch, dass er Woche für Woche 90 Minuten spielt, aus Frosinones zu hören. Der trainiert auch wie ein Irrer, also im positiven Sinn. Der hat einen Kopf an der richtigen Stelle, der will. Und bei Juve ist es mittlerweile schon so weit, dass Juve anscheinend probiert, den im Winter vielleicht schon wieder zurückzuholen quasi. Aber Frosinone scheint da ganz gut gerüstet zu sein, zu sagen, nee, komm, das war ausgemacht bis Ende des Jahres. Das lasst man vielleicht auch so. Also für seine Entwicklung wäre es sicher das Beste, wenn er auch noch bleibt. Sehr spannender Spieler.
Stark. Und wer ist dein Anzang Hero? Kannst du gleich weitermachen.
Ja, Anzang Hero ist jetzt vielleicht nicht der typische Anzang Hero, aber das Inter-Frosinone-Spiel vor der Länderspielpause. Da hat Federico Di Marco, wer es noch nicht gesehen hat, darf sich das gerne mal kurz anschauen, mal kurz aus 50 Metern getroffen. Und zwar gewollt. Er hat einen Torhüter draußen gesehen. Da gibt es auch Beispiele. Ich kenne Szenen aus dem Inter-Training, wo er solche Geschichten auch schon probiert hat, wo auch schon der eine oder andere eingeschlagen ist. Und jetzt ist klar, Di Marco nicht einer, den niemand auf dem Zettel hat, aber für mich ist er auch einer dieser Figuren, warum Inter im Moment so stabil ist, warum sie ganz klar der Top-Kandidat auf dem Titel sind und auch ihren Run, den sie letztes Jahr in Europa hatten, da auf jeden Fall vom Kopf her auch in der Richtung weitermachen. Di Marco ist ein Inter-Uhrgewächs. Der war als Junge, stand der in der Kurve und der lebt diesen Inter-Spirit. Dementsprechend ist es nicht der klassische Ansang hier, weil gerade nach dem Tor haben alle über ihn geredet. Aber er ist für mich ein Symbol dafür, dass bei Inter sehr, sehr viel gut läuft und dass eben auch ein Grund mit dafür ist, dass da Spieler sind. Und Di Marco ist genau der, der das am meisten verkörpert, der sozusagen über Leihgeschäfte sich sozusagen in den Inter-Kader reingespielt hat. Und jetzt halt auch diese Interista-DNA total verkörpert und damit wirklich eine wichtige Rolle einnimmt.
Sehr schön. Alexi, du darfst uns deinen Unsung Hero, ich weiß nicht, was Unsung Hero auf Französisch hieße, aber du darfst uns das nennen. Na, der unbesungene Held. Also Alexi, wem würdest du gerne nominieren? Ach so, nein, ach so, ich dachte, das wäre eine ironische Frage gewesen. Entschuldigung, es ist quasi jemand, der nicht so im Licht der Öffentlichkeit steht, aber es eigentlich verdient hätte, weil er eben starke Leistungen bringt, aber halt vielleicht ein bisschen untergeht gegenüber anderen Leuten, die normalerweise aus 50 Metern treffen. Da haben wir jetzt das schlechteste Beispiel. Gibt es da jemanden, wo du sagst...
Spontan, ein ex Schalker, Jean-Pierre Todi Bode, der momentan das Innenverteidiger-Duo bildet. Beste Abwehr Europas, 4 Gegentore in 13 Spielen. Er hat sich super entwickelt. Ich hatte ihn damals als sehr arrogant, als er bei Schalke war, kennengelernt. Und hat sich positiv entwickelt, nämlich ein bisschen bescheidener. Aber wenn du so lange mit Dante das Innenverteidiger-Duo bildest, dann wirst du ein bisschen bescheidener und professioneller im aktuellen Leben. Und er hat sich wirklich fantastisch entwickelt. Er ist sehr komplett als Verteidiger. Er begreift alles vom modernen Verteidigerspiel heute. Er ist zweikampfstark, beidfüßig, hat ein sehr gutes Stellungsspiel. Er wird in der kommenden Saison ganz sicher womöglich bei Ulis Lieblingsliga kicken. Und nicht bei Bernhardsson, sondern eher weiter nach oben.
Das wird zu sinnvoll, um es nicht zu können.
Zu sinnvoll, als das es Manchester United machen würde. So ist doch eigentlich richtig. Aber gut, das ist ein anderes Thema. Ich sehe, du hast einen Fan für diesen Pick. Und weil du gleich los musst, Alexi, magst du uns auch schon deinen Moment des Spieltags vielleicht nennen. Was war denn so eine Geschichte in der Ligue 1, die man vielleicht nicht so mitbekommen hat, die aber wichtig zu erwähnen ist? Ja, oder auch in den letzten Wochen gerne.
Ja, ich habe es wahrscheinlich schon darüber gesprochen, aber das abgebrochene Spiel Marcel Lyon, bzw. nicht angepfiffene, weil der Bus, der Lyonär hier angerufen wurde, wird jetzt nachgeholt in ganz gleichen Konditionen. Also im Start-Velodrom von Marcel mit Fans. Wenn Großhoch bis dahin immer noch der Trainer ist, wie wird er dieses Spiel angehen? Psychisch? Er wird ständig wahrscheinlich rechts und links schauen, wenn man dem Start-Velodrom immer näher kommt. Auf jeden Fall furchtbar, dass da der Liga-Verband, auch wenn Olympie Marseille nichts dafür kann, weil es nicht im Stadion war oder ums Stadion, sollte man schon mal hätte der Liga-Verband da symbolisch auf den Tisch hauen müssen. Und das haben sie natürlich nicht gemacht. Wieder ziemlich feige gewesen. Und das überwährt natürlich wieder mal ein schlechtes Image über den französischen Verein Fußball. Und das nur neun Monate vor den Olympischen Spielen in Paris, die auch schon viel Sorgen bereiten, was die Sicherheit anbelangt und die Organisation.
Okay, da können wir gespannt sein, wie dieses Nachos-Spiel laufen wird. Alexi, falls du los musst, dann herzlichen Dank. Ansonsten kannst du auch noch gerne... Bis bald mal wieder, ne? Und wir machen weiter im Moment. Jetzt bin ich durcheinander gekommen. Uli, kannst du uns noch einen Ansagenhero nennen?
Ich habe einen, der noch nie in seinem Leben besungen worden ist. Also wirklich die Definition eines Ansagenheroes. Den Namen werdet ihr wahrscheinlich nicht mehr gehört haben. Thomas Kaminski heißt der Gute. Ist Borderline-Kaderspieler Belgiens. Auf der Torhüterposition wird aber nie ein Länderspiel machen, weil es einfach zu viele Gute davor gibt. Aber ist der synkuläre Grund dafür, dass Lutentown überhaupt noch mit dabei ist. Im Irgendwas hat es sechs Expected Goals gehalten. Das ist ein absoluter Top-Wert. Ich glaube sogar in Europa. Ich habe es nach dem Spiel nicht mehr gecheckt, aber vor dem Spiel war es jedenfalls so. Hat auch gegen United wieder zwei, drei Dinge rausgeholt, die einfach gar nicht möglich sind. Super im 1 gegen 1, spielt super lange Bälle als Torhüter. Und kam eigentlich aus der zweiten Liga von Blackburn, wo er jetzt nicht total überragend war. War auch nicht gesichert, dass der die Nummer 1 sein würde bei Luten. Das hat Rob Edwards lang offen gelassen. Aber im Moment gibt es da überhaupt nichts zu diskutieren. Ist einer der leistungsstärksten Spieler überhaupt in der Premier League. Und den hätte ich genauso gut als MVP nehmen können. Luten hat einen Kader, der bestenfalls Mittelmaß-2. Liga ist. Sie sind trotzdem mit dabei. Das liegt zum einen am Trainer, der das schon ganz ordentlich macht. Aber vor allen Dingen an Kaminski. Deswegen muss der mal genannt werden. Und das ist ja wirklich Ansagen. Weil, glaube ich, das ist nie passiert.
Ja, absolut fantastisch. Hat vorher bei Blackburn lange gespielt. Und nein, das wusste ich nicht auswendig. Das wäre ja ein bisschen komisch. Dann kannst du uns auch gerne, wenn du willst, schon deinen Moment nachliefern, Uli. Was war denn so besonders bemerkenswert in den letzten Wochen?
Also der Moment war, als der WEA einmal richtig lag. Wir haben ein großes Problem mit England gerade. Aber im Ernst ist es relativ einfach. Und das hat jetzt gar nichts mit dem Sportlichen zu tun. Aber gestern gab es das Bild, das um die Welt ging, Louis Dias mit seinem Vater, der knappe zwei Wochen in Gefangenschaft war, gekidnappt wurde. Und am Donnerstag, ganz kurz vor dem Europa-League-Spiel Liverpool in Toulouse, ist die Meldung gekommen, dass er befreit worden ist. Jetzt ist ja Louis Dias heimgeflogen zur Qualifikation, also mit der Nationalmannschaft, und hat dann seinen Papa Davide getroffen. Und diese ganze Sache, so traurig zunächst der Hintergrund, ja, war logischerweise immer noch ein riesengroßes Problem in Kolumbien, oder generell in Südamerika, vor allen Dingen in Kolumbien, dass eben die Familien der Spieler total unsicher sind. Aber als es dann Gott sei Dank glimpflich über die Bühne ging, diese Momente, auch denen ging ja schon zuvor, dass Louis Dias ein Tor macht in der Nachspielzeit, als er ja für eine Woche circa raus war, ist alles nicht nachzuvollziehen, was da passiert, auch nicht nachzufühlen, also gar nicht zu greifen irgendwie. Und trotzdem dann so schön, dass es wenigstens gut ging, nach all dem Materium, das da wahrscheinlich passiert sein muss, also die Details, ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich die jemals wissen will, aber deswegen ist das sicher der Moment, das hat nichts mit Fußball zu tun, ist aber auch ganz gleich.
Ja, sehr schön. Siehst du, das hatte ich nämlich zum Beispiel gar nicht mitbekommen, dass es da jetzt auch die Zusammenführung der beiden wieder gab. Nils, sag uns doch mal deinen Ansang Hero und gerne auch dann gleich deinen Moment hinterher.
Ich musste noch überlegen, kann ich irgendwie noch Atletico und Basel mit reinkriegen? Ich glaube, ich kriege Sinn. Ich dachte beim Ansagen Hero vielleicht auch erst an den Ivar Racket hinstellen, wie es Sevilla noch hilft. Aber ich gehe mal zu Atletico. Denn dort gibt es einen, der wurde lange als Chancentod betitelt und auch belächelt, natürlich auch von Madridistas, weil er aus Real Madrid-Jugend kommt, aber Alvaro... Leider nein. Aber Alvaro Morata spielt eine Riesensaison, weil er endlich auch die vermeintlich einfachen Tore macht. Also mit auch Nationalmannschaft hat er in 19 Spielen 16 Tore gemacht, plus noch ein paar Vorlagen. Also er steht auch dafür, dass Atletico das beste Team im Kalender ja 23 bei in der Liga ist oder teilweise auch in Europa. Mitten im Kießmann zusammen, Super-Duo, er knipset endlich, wie gesagt, ist auch als Joker griffig, hat da keine Probleme damit, wenn er auch mal auf der Bank sitzt. Also er funktioniert gut und verdient sich da mal ein paar Gesänge und nicht nur ironische Gesänge, wie das vielleicht früher mal war. Und als Moment, speziell des Spieltags des 13., habe ich mir was von Barca rausgenommen. Die haben nämlich schon wieder ein extrem früheres Gegentor kassiert. Jetzt gegen Alaves war es in der 18. Sekunde, hat Samu Omorodion getroffen. Vorher, ein paar Wochen vorher in Granada, war Brian Saragossa schon nach 17 Sekunden erfolgreich. Und das ist ein Rekord, so gesehen in der Liga, oder das gab es noch nie, dass eine Mannschaft innerhalb einer Saison in zwei Spielen innerhalb der ersten 20 Sekunden Gegentore kassiert. Da hat jetzt Barca auch für einen kleinen Negativrekord, das ist für mich der Moment des Spieltags.
Aber waren denn das... Es gibt ja inzwischen so Spielzüge, die vom Anpfiff weg gespielt werden. War das so, oder einfach langer Ball nach vorne und dann gebielen?
Das ist das Lustige. Barca hatte Anstoß jetzt gegen Alaves und hat versucht, mit gleich sieben Spielern anzugreifen. Die waren alle schon an der Mittellinie, alle gehen vor. Alaves hat dann leicht den Ball irgendwie abgefangen. Oder zumindest in die andere, in Barca's Hälfte gebracht. Dort an Ilkay Gündogan den Ball ein bisschen schlampeig, müde verloren. Aber dann dahinter waren auch noch drei, vier Verteidiger, die dann auch nicht so griffig gewesen. Und dann tatsächlich Umorodi und, ich glaube, noch Testegen getunnelt. Also da hatte Alaves eigentlich nicht so viel mit zu tun. Das war jetzt nichts Einstudiertes, weil Barca hatte Anstoß.
Ja, aber das macht ja eigentlich wirklich noch lustiger, muss man sagen. Also sorry für alle Barca-Fans. Aber naja, wisst ihr ja selber auch, wie es gemeint ist. Dann fehlt uns nur noch ein Moment, und zwar der aus der Serie A. Christian?
Ja, der liegt in der Zukunft, aber in der sehr nahen Zukunft, das Gute. Nach der Länderspielpause gibt es Juve-Inter. Und Juve-Inter ist immer Juve-Inter. Das ist das emotionalste Duell in Italien. Und jetzt kommt der Punkt dazu, dass Juve ja auch es geschafft hat, an Inter dran zu bleiben bisher, was Milan und Napoli eben nicht geschafft haben. Juve ist eine Effizienzmaschine vor dem Herrn. Also Allegri spielt Allegri-Fußball. Wir haben ihn noch nie in dieser Ausprägung spielen lassen. Sie kassieren kaum was. Das für mich das sinnbildlichste Spiel war vor kurzem in Florenz gegen die Fiorentiner. Die Fiorentiner hat gemacht, getan. Juve stand hinten drin, aber stand gut hinten drin. Die Fiorentiner, Achtung Max, das ist für dich, hat 50 Flanken gebracht.
Hoffentlich haben sie 0 zu 1 verloren.
Ja genau, sie haben 0 zu 1 verloren. Diese defensive Stabilität muss man auch dazu sagen. Es fehlt im Moment Danilo, wo man dachte, das ist eigentlich der, der diese defensive Stabilität Juve gibt, aber seitdem spielten Rougani und der macht das hinten genauso gut. Also Allegri hat diese Defensivstruktur seiner Mannschaft wieder eingeimpft. Bremer, Rougani, Gatti, Köpfen hinten alles raus, sind aber auch gut organisiert. Das soll gar nicht despektierlich klingen. Du musst auch tief gut verteidigen können. Und es kann Juve. Und jetzt gibt es Juve-Inter. Juve ist zwei Punkte dran. Das Ding ist schon seit dem letzten Spiel vor der Länderspielpause angezündet in Italien. Es wird eigentlich nur darüber geredet. Deswegen komm in den Sonntag, 26. November. Da wird es in Turin brennen.
Christian Bernhard, du bist so ein gottverdammter Fuchs. Jetzt haben wir keine Zeit für die Matches to Watch. Und dann sagst du dir, das packe ich einfach in den Moment des Spieltags rein und lass alle anderen damit doof aussehen. Aber es sei dir gegönnt. Danke, Christian, dass du mit dabei warst. Danke an Uli Hebel. Dich kann man natürlich auch auf rondo.tv sehen. Werde ich alles verlinken in den Show Notes. Und danke an Nils Kern. Da gibt es natürlich auch mit Viva la Liga die neue Plattform zum spanischen Fußball. Danke dir, lieber Nils, dass du hier warst. Was auch immer das jetzt genau geheißen hat. Es hat mir Spaß gemacht oder es war irgendwie schön? Ich hoffe, dass das wirklich die Übersetzung ist. Ansonsten werden es mir die Hörerinnen und Hörer sagen. Danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Da draußen im Rasenfunk geht es bald weiter. Auf rasenfunk.de findet ihr noch ganz viele andere Sendungen. Empfiehlt uns bitte weiter und unterstützt uns. rasenfunk.de/supporterscluboder mit Blick auf weihnachtenkiosk.rasenfunk.de. Bleibt gesund, macht's gut, ciao. Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank.